Now let's discuss the solution to our dependencies and
hazards quiz. First, let's figure out the dependencies. Again,
dependencies are a property of the program alone so
we don't have to worry about the pipeline yet.
Each of these instructions has a dependence on R1
from the add to that instruction. Which of these
dependencies or hazards does depend on the pipeline? To
check whether the dependence is a hazard, we need
to figure out when does the read of
the register happen and when does it get written.
In the stage where the subtract is reading
the register, the add is still writing it, so
the subtract may not get the value from the add, so there is a hazard here. In
the cycle when the divide is reading the register
R1, the subtract is here and the add has
left the pipeline, which means the divide is reading the value
of R1 that was already written by the add. So there is
no hazard here and, of course, the multiply reads the same
register one cycle after the divide so it also has no hazard.